well what is the first thing that comes
to your mind when you think of craft
beer well apparently this is a really
kind of evolving industry and perhaps
some of the long-held beliefs of what
it's all about are changing Heather
Mills takes us to Henderson where the
real Buzz is the Brewers
the craft beer movement is filtering out
old stereotypes it's usually like a big
Burly guy with a beard that you know
likes cars and you know listens to rock
music now more than half of Millennials
drink craft beer on a weekly basis and
the Brewers Association says a quarter
are women but when it comes to owning a
brewery men still outnumber women three
to one
it's no secret that the craft beer
industry is still a male dominated
industry but it is changing Wendy Forest
is the president of the Nevada craft
Brewers Association and co-owns craft
house with her husband Dave I like to
Buck the system a lot and that didn't
shy me away but really what drew me into
the craft beer industry is the sense of
community when they opened crafthouse in
2014 Wendy pushed for updated laws
regulating the industry so they could
build that Community making it possible
for others to open in Henderson then
launched a brand with impact we opened
with a female head Brewer Steph cope
windy is quick to point out though Steph
was the best person for the job not just
because she was female she's just a
great Brewer
period but a female head Brewer is still
unique
going somewhat Against the Grain in
southern Nevada two women here at bad
beat Brewing are hopping on a nationwide
Trend putting a chill on stereotypes
this is Amanda Keller head Brewer at bad
beat Brewing just across the way from
Craft House part of the community from
like a brewer standpoint I love having
two other breweries here because like
we're really close with the other
Brewers she has a degree from UNLV and
completed the master Brewers program at
UC Davis physics and biochemistry and
microbiology still she wasn't sure it
was enough 2015 when I graduated and
came back to Las Vegas the Brewing
industry was just budding at that time
and I was really worried I wouldn't be
able to get a brewing job here but she
did though she admits at times it was
still a boys club at events and
conferences he was our sellerman and I
was the Brewer and everybody would talk
to him and he's like I'm not the Brewer
talk to her then she got the call from
bad beat they needed a head Brewer it
was her shot sometimes I will sit back
and think you know wow this is you know
so much easier now than it used to be
and she's passing on her knowledge
Becca Halpin also a Trailblazer was able
to come in without a science degree easy
to learn the step-by-step process open
this valve press this button you know
add this at this time but learning why
things react the way they react is just
so much more vast and takes takes years
to really figure that out but she says
she feels confident in her roles
assistant Brewer because of the culture
at bad beat they're doing it for the
community around you for other people
that can enjoy it and you can enjoy it
too and these ladies certainly do I
can't believe that this is what I do for
a living Heather Mills eight news now
so there are laws on the books that make
it more difficult for Nevada craft
Brewers Nevada must follow a three-tier
system in order to distribute meaning
product must be sold to a wholesaler
before it sold to a retailer the Nevada
craft Brewers Association is working on
changing more of those laws though in
the upcoming legislative session